belle l'une des plus importantes
entreprises au canada un nouveau pdg qui
occupe ses nouvelles fonctions depuis ce
matin mirecourt biblique succède à john
peel est notre invité ce soir bonsoir
monsieur biblique
bonsoir monsieur client vous êtes avec
bell depuis 2004 vous connaissez cette
entreprise-là par cas il ya eu toute une
transition au cours des derniers mois
mais qu'est ce que ça fait qu'est ce que
ça signifie pour vous d'être aujourd'hui
le pdg de la plus grande entreprise de
télécommunications au canada sont
journée de grande fierté et un
montréalais c'est une compagnie comme
belle compagnie avec une grande histoire
marque iconique et dans une grosse
journée à chaque chaque fois qu'un
nouveau pdg de pdg pour une entreprise
c'est une grosse journée pour
l'entreprise pour moi personnellement
oui une grosse journée aussi journée
pleine de fierté
en effet c'est la réalisation de rêves
c'est la réalisation d'un rêve c'est la
réalisation d'un de la prochaine étape
de ma carrière et c'est spécial et donc
vous êtes à la tête de cette entreprise
qui est importante au canada et un rôle
important qu'ils canadiens connaissent
très très bien dans les priorités que
vous avez énoncé on parle du 5 juin 10
sur la cinquième génération après le 4
juin de 5 juillet un secteur des
télécommunications est ce que c'est pour
maintenant très bientôt de 5 g chez bell
au canada est-ce que c'est dès 2020
qu'on commence à déployer le réseau
pourrait on est au tout début d'une
nouvelle ère de communication
t'as pas moins tout début en passons 5 g
comme vous l'avez mentionné l'internet
des objets l'intelligence artificielle
la fibre optique
le tout propulseur la nouvelle économie
moderne du canada est au centre de tout
ça ce sont nos réseaux ou les réseaux de
l'industrie des télécoms donc on parle
de région 5 g si on parle de réjouissent
de 5,5 g spécifiquement le vrai 5 g sera
lancée en 2020 il nous faut du spectre
du gouvernement fédéral
il y en aura les enchères à la fin de
l'année mais le
le prix 5 g 10 on en a rien dit lolif
hadji sera un peu plus tard cette année
avec le lancement d'appareils
cellulaires de plusieurs manufacturiers
et donc est ce que vous croyez qu'au
canada on doit approuver l'installation
le déploiement des réseaux de huawei est
un très très bon partenaire
en effet c'est une des raisons qu'on est
que bell des mers réseau sans fil au
monde
on utilise en partie les équipements de
huawei comme fournisseur sans fil
on aimerait avoir le choix de
fournisseurs d'équipements de télécoms
des qualités dont huawei en est un mais
ce qu'on vrai ce qu'on recherche
vraiment du gouvernement fédéral c'est
de la clarté de nous énoncer les règles
et on s'ajustera à en conséquence mais
vous avez bel fait confiance à bombay sa
confiance à hawaï en utilisent d'autres
fournisseurs comme nous qu'il ya aussi
ont fait confiance très confiance à nos
clients en hockey aussi quand on parle
de belles pour les gens c'est la facture
c'est à dire c'est les
télécommunications de tous les
fournisseurs de télécommunications est
quand même une grande frustration au
canada on a l'impression qu'on paie très
cher pour nous c'est russe de
télécommunications et le bureau de la
concurrence dit avant les fêtes qu'on
pourrait baisser ses coûts de façon
importante s'ils avaient plus de
concurrence dans les marchés régionaux
qu'est ce que bell peut faire pour
baisser la facture des canadiens c'est
la concurrence qui va continuer à offrir
de la valeur aux consommateurs
et il y en a beaucoup de concurrence au
canada les raisons qui est beaucoup plus
on a beaucoup et c'est à cause qu'on
encourage les investissements ce qui se
passe c'est que tous les joueurs
essaient d'avoir deux mers réseau sans
fil au canada et même au monde
ça crée des incitatifs aux autres
fournisseurs d'essayer de battre on
essaie de se battre tous les jours les
puis ben là ce qu'on offre aux canadiens
et les meilleurs réseaux m'ont une
couverture énorme à travers le pays et
des prix abordables
on a une offre de la valeur de la valeur
ajoutée jésus est un petit peu the
ripper un minable parce que quand on
fait les comparaisons et sinon tu
essaies fait ça chaque année au canada
toujours parmi les plus virulents avec
les amicales et faut se baser sur des
faits donc le crtc dans leurs rapports
récents ont constaté que les prix ont
diminué au canada de 35% de 2017 à 2018
et ça ça ne compte pas ce qui ce qui
s'est passé à l'été en 2019 ou
l'industrie a offert des forfaits
illimités qui offre beaucoup de valeur
aux consommateurs une autre chose qu'il
faut aussi constater c'est très très
important c'est que si on rend dans la
gazet notre pendant le temps des fêtes
par exemple les fournisseurs aux frais
aux consommateurs des cartes cadeaux de
400 à 500 dollars de valeur ça c'est les
cartes cadeaux les primes de ce genre ne
sont jamais considérés dans les analyses
qui compare les prix
parmi les pays donc est ce qu'il ya un
enjeu où il n'y a pas d'enjeu sur le
prix des télécommunications
ce conte 9 on a de la valeur ajoutée il
faut considérer trois facteurs les
prises d'importantes jaloux c'est
important mais les prix baissent à
chaque année la qualité parce qu'on paye
aussi pour la qualité et la couverture
et si on veut vraiment on veut une
économie moderne au canada qui est basée
sur l'infrastructure de communication il
faut investir
c'est impossible d'avoir les plus brader
plus batterie au monde la mère qualité
au monde et la plus grande couverture au
monde vous faire pour rendre vos clients
plus heureux parce que quand on regarde
les plaintes en matière de
télécommunications d'abord les plaintes
augmentent à la commission des plaintes
et 30 % des plaintes sont contre bell
canada
c'était c'est important l'expérience
client très important j'en suis très
conscient en effet ce matin en dévoilant
nos interactif stratégique
l équipe à l'interné aux investisseurs
j'ai annoncé qu'un des critères un des
impératifs important c'était de
promouvoir l'expérience client
je dois renforcer comme pdg à l'équipe à
tous les jours qu'on doit rendre de
faire en sorte de rendre de faire
affaire avec elle tout facile donc à
chaque fois qu'on s'engage avec un
client leur offrir une expérience qui
est simple positive et enrichissante et
on va le faire à tous les jours
vous allez de l'atteindre jeu très fier
du travail qu'on a qu'on a fait durant
les dernières années pour améliorer le
service à la clientèle
j'avoue qu'à tous les jours on doit
s'améliorer encore on peut le faire à
tous les jours autre dossier le crtc a
jugé avant les fêtes que bell canada a
favorisé indûment rds ça change votre
chaîne de sport en refusant d'inclure
tva sports de quebecor dans le forfait
le plus populaire et le crtc oblige
belle à offrir d'ici le 5 février tv
lasse pas aux mêmes conditions que rds
est ce que vous allez faire on va
s'ajuster avant on a jusqu'au mois de
février 2 le 5 avril je crois pour
reprendre au crtc
on va s'ajuster on considère nos options
une des options serait peut-être de
prendre appel contre la décision
en bout de ligne en bout de ligne
quebecor les chaînes les chaînes de tv à
tevez internes importants fournisseurs
au bell télé bell média important
fournisseur de contenu à vidéotron
on doit de s'entendre on est prêt à
négocier de bonne foi toujours on espère
que quelques le groupe quebecor est prêt
à négocier de bonne foi avec plusieurs
options négocier oui répondent au crtc
formellement ou apporter à décision
parce que la décision ou porter appel
contre la décision - les options vous
n'avez pas décidé encore d'ici un mois
ça doit se régler tout ça c'est bien ça
est ce que vous dites est ce que vous
négocie en ce moment avec quebecor à ce
moment là on négocie on est culte en
prêt à négocier pour dire que l'on
négocie aujourd'hui c'est non négocié ok
dernier mot sur les objectifs financiers
votre marge bénéficiaire votre bénéfice
c'est à peu près 1 43 % de vos revenus
quand on regarde la marge bénéficiaire
quels sont vos objectifs et ce que vous
voulez augmenter la profitabilité la
rentabilité de belles ce qu'on veut
assurer aux et aux actionnaires et aux
investisseurs c'est la stabilité de la
dividende
c'est ce que les et les actionnaires
recherche de nous je constaterai que en
2019 l'action de 2
de baisser enregistré un trio de
rendement et ça se doit de continuer
c'est ça qu'on va faire comme équipe
très bien mirko bibic merci beaucoup
merci monsieur fillon et bonne chance
merci merci